Film Courage: I think there’s a lot of social
pressure and I know for Generation Xers like
myself it’s always existed but now for Millennials
and Generation Z this…not even just the
30 Under 30 of people [who are successful],
now there is 25 under 25.
We see younger and younger people achieving
great things.
Jeffrey Davis: What I tell my students is
great, get into the business in any job you
can get into, pay your dues, and don’t say
“Oh within a year I’ve got to be in a
writer’s room as an assistant.”
Because 9 chances out of 10, it’s not going
to happen.
If the lucky chance that it happens, great
for you!
And then bring your friends along.
Because we tell (particularly grad students)
on the first day of grad school look right
and look left because that’s not just your
posse, those are the people that are going
to hire you.
But LMU [Loyola Marymount University] is not
like other film schools, it’s not competitive,
it’s more collaborative.
I know USC is very competitive and I think
that’s too bad because collaborative environment
is always better to nurture other people while
you’re trying to get what you want, that
means that you will always have people that
you’re working with.
Most of my seniors come out and if they haven’t
changed their mind about writing, they work.
They are all listed.
This crop of seniors that just graduated in
May, they’re all working in the business.
Peter Desberg: But we will want to edit out
all of the bad stuff about USC out of there.
Jeffrey Davis: Nahhh!
Keep it in.
Peter Desberg: [Raising his hand] USC graduate
here.
Film Courage: Well, we can ask this thought
(no schools mentioned though), how can one
tell a collaborative environment versus competitive.
Because sometimes competitive can mask as
collaborative and then once you’ve been
around a little bit [in this environment]
you start to see “No…”
Jeffrey Davis: They care not just about their
own work but other people’s work, are they
involved?
Do they work on other people’s work?
I think that’s a big tell.
And what are the teachers like?
What are your bosses like?
Now the difference between school and a job.
If your boss is not a nice person, there’s
not much you can do about that except quit.
And it’s good for you to work for mean people
(I think) because you will learn especially
early on, you will learn how to deal with
difficult people.
It’s just a part of life.
Look, I have to work with Peter everyday.
Peter Desberg: But you’ve asked a really
nuanced question.
Jeffrey Davis: Which is another pedagogical
term - nuanced.
Film Courage: Oh good!
I’m “nuanced.”
Peter Desberg: Because you’re making it
sound like it’s binary.
Are you collaborative…
Jeffrey Davis: We don’t know the word binary,
Peter.
Film Courage: 0, 0, 1…
Jeffrey Davis: She’s thinking mathematically.
He means it’s not one or the other.
Peter Desberg: I’ll get my answer in.
I’m patient just like Adam.
Jeffrey Davis: If you start speaking English,
perhaps?
Peter Desberg: And so the fact is in any environment
the difference, the places where you find
it’s competitive, you’ll find people being
very evaluative, particularly negatively evaluative.
“That’s not a good idea because…”
“That wouldn’t work because…”
Jeffrey Davis: I don’t allow that in my
class.
Peter Desberg: But good ideas are always recognized.
So it’s always competitive because if you
have the best ideas, you’re recognized as
the best.
Like LMU works really hard to be a supportive
environment, yet here was this student who
was clearly head and shoulder above everybody
else.
You’re going to get noticed by the quality
of your ideas.
So it’s competitive to the extent that you
could stratify who are the best of the worst
writers whether you’re supportive or competitive.
But the difference is the lumps you take along
the way.
In other words some people again come with
this idea of “Look it’s an aggressive
marketplace.
We want to prepare you for it.”
So if your ideas aren’t so great, we’re
going to let you know it because you won’t
have so many not-so-great ideas later as opposed
to other places.
I mean, I know for example people come to
me all the time with ideas saying “Can you
give me notes?
Here’s my script, etc.”
And what I found…
Jeffrey Davis: You should charge for that
I think.
Peter Desberg: What I find is I almost never
give criticisms.
What I do is I ask questions and so if something
doesn’t work for me, I don’t say “That
doesn’t work.”
or “That’s no good.”
I say “Have you thought about this?”
Or “Why is it work to have this be that?
Or is there another way to do that?”
So it’s never coming out as a put-down because
people get very defensive when you put their
stuff down.
Jeffrey Davis: It doesn’t help them either.
Peter Desberg: And I don’t want to dampen
their enthusiasm and at the same point I don’t
think it’s helpful.
We’re asking them thought-provoking questions
that they can answer.
Eventually if they are smart enough, it’s
a criticism or it’s a flaw, but it’s not
negative, it makes them think “How do I
solve a problem?”
So I like to re-cast it as problem-solving.
Jeffrey Davis: You know I think it helps to
realize that believe it or not Aaron Sorkin
has written some pretty crummy scripts and
he would probably be the first to say so event
he best people…well there’s a famous William
Somerset Maugham saying that only mediocre
writers are at their best all the time.
So I think what I try to do in class and probably
some of this is influenced by Peter is that
(it really hurts to have to compliment him,
physically hurts).
Peter Desberg: You can see the pain in his
face.
You won’t see me kicking his ankle.
Jeffrey Davis: It would have never occurred
to me to say to any student and I haven’t
had the experience of a student with zero
talent.
I’ve never had that because it’s really
hard to get into LMU now and we are number
8 out of 10 top film schools now, so plug
for LMU (Loyola Marymount University).
But even someone who was really untalented
I would probably do what Peter just said I
would probably say do you really want to write
but I would never say “You have no talent
for writing.”
Because a lot of people said that to me, they
didn’t say it in those words but a lot of
people discouraged me and I think discouraging
someone is really awful, it’s an awful thing
to do because you never know what someone
will do later.
Peter Desberg: But let me add…
Jeffrey Davis: Hold on…hold on…stay.
Peter Desberg: I almost got a word in.
Jeffrey Davis: I wasn’t finished with my
speech, I was going to say something nice
about you.
If you had told me 10 years ago when I met
Peter that he was going to write a novel,
I would have said “Peter will never write
a novel.
That’s something Peter doesn’t do.”
He’s not only written a novel, he’s really
working hard on it.
Now you can interrupt me, go ahead.
Peter Desberg: Notice he didn’t say “It’s
really good.”
He said “He’s really working hard.”
Jeffrey Davis: It’s getting there.
Film Courage: Is that the manual?
Peter Desberg: No.
Jeffrey Davis: It’s a historical novel which
by the way is the hardest genre there is.
Peter Desberg: But you know even when you’re
asking questions, I think you have to be really
careful because questions can be very evaluative.
“Why did you decide to wear that dress today?”
Jeffrey Davis: It’s a very pretty dress.
Film Courage: It’s hot outside.
Peter Desberg: The point is that’s a question…
Film Courage: Oh yeah…I’ve had those type
of questions.
Peter Desberg: It’s an evaluation.
Jeffrey Davis: That’s a gender-biased question.
Peter Desberg: Even asking questions “Why
do you want to be writing?”
You have to be very careful because that could
be a very discouraging question.
Film Courage: Well I have an evaluative question
that I would like to ask and that would be
do you think that a writer that has talent
but no connections has an easier time getting
in the business versus a writer that has not
as much talent but connections?
Peter Desberg: That’s a trick question.
Film Courage: It’s not evaluative?
Jeffrey Davis: You’re sneaky.
Peter Desberg: Because it really depends on
the ratios of both.
Jeffrey Davis: It depends on the circumstances,
thats the scientific answer.
Peter Desberg: But I have to tell you contacts…oh
it’s really big!
You know there are an awful lot of people
who will never, never, never get noticed no
matter how good they are because the work
will just never get out of that bottle.
And knowing people, big advantage.
But you know we were talking about this before
today that the importance of the M word in
Hollywood, that networking is more important
than anything.
The more people you can work with, the more
people you can collaborate with, when there’s
a position open in a room you’re a lot more
likely to call friends in than say “Hey,
we got an open spot here.
Come in and audition” So more work gets
given to people who know people than any other
way.
Film Courage: I like what you said about the
evaluative questions though because I think
we’ve all had that happen to us in one form
or another where somebody’s asking a question
and they’re like “I’m just asking a
question!”
But it’s the intention behind the question.
Peter Desberg: Well I had a clinical supervisor
who would really get down on me with “Don’t
make a statement through a question.”
Film Courage: I’m almost afraid to follow
up with something.
Peter Desberg: If I said we’ll use the same
question again “Um…why did you choose
to wear that dress today?”
That’s like saying “That’s not really
an appropriate dress to wear?”
Film Courage: Oh…I can tell the intention…yeah.
Peter Desberg: And so again, you have to be
careful even when you think, “Why does your
character, why did he choose to be a cowboy?”
You know, I’m saying “You shouldn’t
of had him be a cowboy.”
Film Courage: I can see it in your face and
intonation.
Jeffrey Davis: If you are paying for it, I
think that changes the situation.
Peter Desberg: I think the important thing
is when you’re asking questions, to give
the appearance of wanting information rather
than giving an evaluation.
And surprisingly people don’t really like
being evaluated negatively that much.
Film Courage: That is surprising.
Peter Desberg: No matter how much practice
they’ve had.